good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
director here at long now
tonight's long short came to us I think
the first person that sent it to me was
Austin in our office but then several
more people sent it after that it's by
Josh Owens and and even Stewart I think
even sent it but it's a it's a once
again it's a cop-out to doing a film
about long-term thinking in a short form
in that it's a time lapse and in this
case it just seemed to feel so right
because there's nothing like a time
lapse of a city to make you to make it
really feel like the giant super
organism thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right who's gonna do the first 100
year time-lapse a good evening
Stuart brand from the long now
foundation Geoffrey B West has been the
president of Santa Fe Institute for the
last five years and I was on their board
for 14 years never missed a meeting
because looking over the shoulder of the
scientists working there was one of the
most fun things you can imagine the
subject that Santa Fe Institute is
complex adaptive systems and just the
level of discourse is so good there that
the novelist Cormac MacCarthy they can't
chase him out of the building as near as
I can tell them fact he made him
something official right and put him on
the board or something just hangs out
there for the quality of the
conversation but every now and then they
Hall often change science a couple years
ago Geoff West and James Brown macro
ecologist and some others explained a
mystery in biology called climbers law
having to do with scaling in organisms
as they get bigger they get more
efficient but they get slower and not
only explaining the mechanisms of that
but even the mathematics of that it's
pretty good for a physicist whenever you
guys mess around with physics biology
changes but physics doesn't I noticed
not content to stay with that Worrell he
went on to even stranger organisms in a
sense you can see it in this film
the weather blasting by was clearly
something full of originality and full
of power
complex than adaptive the city life
going on with the weather beating
against it clearly complex and adaptive
and also seems to have some structure
and that's what Jeff has been looking at
Jeffrey west
[Applause]
Thank You suit for introduction and
thank you everybody for coming out on a
Monday night to listen to talks about
cities and companies and life getting
faster and so on and thank you to the
long now foundation for having me
so this title actually I really owe to
Stewart and to Kevin a little bit
because I had suggested classic kind of
mundane boring academic title which that
doesn't have the same kind of
provocation and speculation that's
implied in this title but this is in
fact what I'm going to be talking about
and it's really part of something that
is much bigger than answers to these
questions or at least the answers to
these questions really are talking about
at some level the whole question of
sustainability and the question about
whether all of this meaning all of
socio-economic life the kind of life the
human beings have evolved over the last
ten thousand years when we started
forming communities all of this is
actually sustainable and that's really
an underlying theme of everything I'm
going to be talking about tonight and
implicit also in that is kind of an even
bigger question in some ways because to
answer that question we have to ask are
there laws of life that can be
quantified and put into a predictive
framework so we can answer questions
like the one at the top and the one
implied ones implied in the title and
the whole question of sustainability of
socio-economic life you know having car
and lights and being able to make
clothes and to have cities and so on and
so forth
it's really bound up with cities because
cities have been and still are the
crucible of civilization they are the
place where we've come together and they
are they represent what is really the
greatest impact that human beings have
had on this planet are embodied in our
cities and what has been happening in
the last 200 years in the last 200 years
we have at an exponential rate created
urbanization and urbanization has in
many ways created the tsunami of
problems that we feel we have to face in
the beginning of the 21st century
everything from global warming to
questions of the environment to
questions of health pollution disease
financial markets risk economies etc etc
all of these problems in quotes are
generated by cities because that's where
everybody lives just to give you some
numbers when the country was formed when
our country was formed 200 years ago
less than a few percent lived in cities
now more than 82 percent live in cities
two or three years ago the world crossed
the halfway mark more than half of us
now are organized China is building
maybe 300 new cities in the next 20 to
25 years and what I put on the slide
here this remarkable fact that if you
average over the next 40 to 50 years
every week every week a million people
are being urbanized on the planet and
this is going to have a profound effect
on all of us no matter where we live as
we start to get the pressure of
resources and energy and so on to
accommodate all of this so this is a
huge problem
so urbanization and cities are an
extraordinary phenomenon which is
led us to these big problems that we
have to deal with but also as I put up
there urbanization is the solution
because the other remarkable and
fantastic fact about cities is they act
as vacuum cleaners as magnets as hubs
that bring in creative people
that's where ideas are made that's where
wealth is created and that's where the
solutions for these problems if there
are any are to be had
because cities attract creative people I
suspect I don't know but I suspect that
good percentage of you here that live in
San Francisco were not born in San
Francisco I mean there's there's this
extraordinary migration to cities and
you're attracted in fact that film
expresses it to that buzz that
extraordinary buzz that is the essence
of cities so that's what we're gonna be
talking about so before I go into it I
just want to mention Stewart already
mentioned Jim Brown my collaborators in
this these are the people most of these
people have done all the work as I'd
like to think of it I'm the great
bullshitter that comes out and tries to
integrate some of the ideas but I
distinguish here at the top three
because I'm gonna be talking for the
first part of this talk about biology
and organisms and the work that Stewart
referred to was done with at least the
top two gentlemen Jim Brown is very
distinguished ecologist very famous
psychologist Brian is was a student and
postdoc and he is now himself a
distinguished biologist man savage
likewise the blue people are ones that
have been involved primarily with the
city work and in particular I'd like to
mention louise Betancourt who has been a
major collaborator of mine the last
couple of years in this okay so the ten
billion people they're going to inhabit
this planet in 2050 in some form or
another want to live in places like this
the majority of them
want to be in places like this getting
things like this and participating in
places and phenomena like this culture
good restaurants and so on
having iPads and iPod iPod z' and all
the rest of that stuff living in
economies that are continually
increasing and everything's getting
better and the world is going to be
wonderful but they're not physician if
you're a physicist you know that if you
create all that you also have to create
entropy an entropy is disorder which
means essentially that you have to have
phenomena like this this this this and
the real question is is that what San
Francisco is going to look like in 2050
is that what New York is going to look
like London or is it going to look like
this this is our challenge ok so I would
say that in order to address these
problems we desperately need a serious
science of cities to complement our
present more qualitative thinking and by
science of cities I really mean what I
mentioned before a much more
quantitative hopefully mathematize
double predictive kind of theoretical
conceptual framework where we can come
to address these questions in a credible
fashion and this is very much meant to
be to complement traditional methods and
so it's just to repeat again what I said
earlier
are there universal quantifiable
principles that underlie the fabric of
our lives ok so the two questions I
posed myself in addressing this work are
these two our citizen companies just
very large organisms they're just part
of biology we all grew out of biology
all of this stuff came from biology and
the question is is San Francisco an
elephant New York a great big whale is
Microsoft The Beehive
and if they are in what way are they we
often use you know in the literature
people use biological metaphors all the
time you talk about the ecology of the
marketplace the DNA of the company the
metabolism of the city and so are those
just qualitative kind of metaphors or is
there a serious substance to it and if
so the question that is implied in the
title to this talk how come then that
cities don't seem to die it's as
extraordinarily difficult to kill a city
we know classic cases but are the
millions of communities upon me that
have grown on this planet almost all of
them are still with us we've dropped
atom bombs on cities and 30 years later
they're thriving so it's very hard to
kill a city very easy to kill a company
of the millions of companies that are
continually coming through and I will
show you data at the very end almost all
of them die and the kind of mean
lifetime of all companies is about 10
years they're very very few companies
that are more than one to two hundred
years old and most of those are in very
special niches like breweries and
wineries and so on and the question is
can we develop a serious theory so that
we can determine predict that's the
provocative question when Google and
Microsoft are going to go bust this is
the kind of question or is that
impossible and so on so we'll that's
gonna be towards the end of the talk so
here are just some of the
characteristics of life but there are
also characteristics of social organisms
and I'm not going to read them you can
read you can see them for yourself but
all of them of course you're familiar
with but all of them have their
metaphors and analogues in social
organizations and this is what I've
already said I just want to repeat it
again as a physicist coming to this it
is the question are there any universal
kind of laws regularities that can lead
to a predictive kind of theory so it's
this is this is something actually sent
to me by my daughter recently which I've
adapted to this so you know you want to
ask
are there laws governing this kind of
cartoon and as was so this is the
question is this is what I want to do
and I claim this is what we should be
doing in order to really understand what
the hell is going on okay
so take a good look I'll leave it there
for a second so you get it
okay so put slightly differently is that
just another version of this now this
which are very familiar with just a
forest looks like some random collection
of trees and leaves and little plants
and so on but it isn't
it actually has extraordinary regularity
and structure and you can see that by
asking a whole bunch of questions like
how many trees are there of a given size
how far do you have to walk from a tree
of a given size to another tree of
roughly the same size how many branches
of a given size is each one of those
trees have how many leaves does it have
how much energy is flowing through each
branch how big is each canopy etc etc
any question you can think of in a
general way about that forest you can
answer and put in a map with a
mathematical formula and predict
everything about the generic structure
of that forest not only that forest but
any forest across the globe and so
there's a theoretical framework which I
will talk about briefly shortly that can
describe and predict everything on the
average what we call coarse grained
about that forest and any forest on the
planet and one of the reasons for this
is something that's truly remarkable
about life and is crucial for its
resilience and robustness and that is
the phenomenon of scalability meaning
that the same phenomena can be
manifested over extraordinary scales as
as is given shown in this slide this is
just us this is us mammals going over a
range of a hundred million in size from
the tiny shrew that sits on the palm of
my hand to the whale the blue whale
which is bigger than this building and
just to remind you because everybody
forgets this first of all everybody
forgets so this is the biggest animal
that has ever existed on this planet
secondly that up there that little box
up there is the shoe on the scale of the
size of the elephant that doesn't
surprise you but what does surprise most
people is that this is an elephant on
the scale of a whale Jinxy whale is I
would like to use four-letter words but
it is very very very big and the
extraordinary thing about this is that
these are scaled versions one another
even though they look different and I'm
going to emphasize that in a moment but
they look very different but the same
physics and chemistry the same
organization the same functionality
exists through all of these and it works
over this extraordinary range which you
can take it further because life itself
actually scales in a systematic way from
the thing in the top left-hand corner
which is a little engine it's a little
engine that's a cartoon of the molecules
that produce something called ATP which
is your currency of energy that's what's
keeping all of us alive here is that
little engine and there are up to a
thousand of those little engines inside
the next little box which is called a
mitochondrion and there's up to a
thousand of those mitochondria inside
each one on each cell and there's a cell
in the top right hand corner and all of
those have to work in some extraordinary
coherent fashion all of those little
engines have to work together so that
mitochondrion can work together properly
and all those mitochondria have to work
together so the cell can function and
then you take ten to the fourteenth of
those cells and you put them together
and then
things like this and this and all of
those have to work in this extraordinary
integrated coherent fashion so that I
can be up here waving my hands and
passionately telling you how
extraordinary all this is because it
doesn't stop there it makes all this
stuff including this so something
extraordinary is happening that thing up
in the left-hand corner is they're
making this that's what we're doing
we're just scaled versions making this
so how in the hell can all that work
over several billion years if there
aren't regularities and laws that have
emerged by natural selection that are
somehow constraining these so that it
doesn't all fall apart in ten minutes it
doesn't it lasts for billions of years
except for this piece which we don't
know this has only lasted in some cases
for a few hundred maybe we can talk of
thousands of years and that's what we're
going to be discussing now we talked
about scalability but each one of us in
this room has scaled if that's called
growth you've scaled up and that's how
you scaled except this happens we're at
but it could have been you and what it
is is weight versus age for little rats
and there it is it's what you recognize
you grow quickly and then you stop it's
very important that we stop because
that's also part of our own resilience
we won we stopped growing and the same
theory with the same principles that
gave the description of that forest
believe it or not when applied to the
growth of a rat gives that line that's
the prediction and those points are data
so it's the same theory so we have kind
of this generic universal theory can
describe many things of biology and the
thing that is interesting is the think
the question is can we take that kind
these kinds of ideas which I will
elaborate on in a minute
and apply them to companies and
economies now let's go back to this this
is great for us and it has been very
very important this kind of what we call
sigmoidal growth stop growing very
important for our resilience and the
resilience of all of biology all of life
however this is very very very bad if
you're an economy or a city or a company
it's considered very bad because you
stopped growing very bad what we want to
see is this this here is this is
revenues versus age for a bunch of
software companies and you see they
don't look like this they look like this
they're hockey sticks or J's right
they're all going up and everybody in
back those companies are making millions
and billions of dollars and they all
live south of here and you know around
here I don't know and they will look
like this growth very very this is
crucial this is the paradigm and to
which we live and the paradigm that has
led all of you to bear to come here in
your cars and to go back to knife it's
nice comfortable homes but it's
different than this that's the message
ok oops
and sorry and there's the economy that
drives it that's also continues however
there's a dark side to our growth which
is this and there's a dark side to the
growth of companies which is this as I
said all companies end up like this
like we do and that's actually just
parenthetically extremely important very
very good the company's dying it's very
very good that we die so that we can
evolve the new things come new ideas
happen for us over hundreds of thousands
of years millions of years we evolved
this is much shorter time discovered
it's very important so that new things
can evolve into the economy well let me
into this a little bit more
quantitatively a little more of the
science and his and remarkable graph
that was actually referred to in
Stuart's introduction this is called
playas law and it is what it is is
plotted on the vertical axis is
something is metabolic rate so that's
how much energy you need per second to
stay alive it's your it's your mm food
calories a day okay that's what that's
plotted there and it's plotted versus
the weight the mass of a bunch of
organisms and there it is and it's
plotted in this kind of curious way in
order to get everybody on this plot you
notice it's not linear it goes up by
factors of 10 110 100 watts and here 110
100 thousand kilograms so you can get
everyone on the same plot and what you
see is something truly remarkable namely
despite the fact that all these
organisms represent maybe the most
diverse and complex phenomenon in the
universe nevertheless they've all lined
up on this very simple line plotted this
way so out of this complexity this
extraordinary complexity or underlying
this extraordinary complexity is some
extraordinary simplicity and this is
remarkable because we believe that each
one of these organisms evolved with it
in its own unique environmental niche
with its own unique evolutionary history
so each each one of these organisms
including us is historically contingent
depending on all kinds of phenomenon
during evolutionary its evolutionary
history and so you would have expected
when you plot something like this these
things to be all over the place
representing the individuality and the
individual history geography environment
etc of each one of these not only each
one of these organisms but each
subsystem each organ each cell type etc
each one has its
evolutionary history and yet magically
they've all lined up in some very into
some very very simple way and this is
called incidentally sub linear scaling
because the other interesting thing
about this graph is that the slope of
this just the gradient of this is 3/4 so
it only goes up in the way we plotted
here don't he goes up three times four
four times moving along here now that
3/4 is less than one that's why we call
it sub linear and that has an
interesting consequence because if it
were linear if it had been linear what
does that mean that means if you double
the size of an organism you would double
the amount of energy it would need and
that's what you would have expected
because you double the number of cells
so you would expect it double the amount
of energy to support it what this says
is you don't need double that 3/4
actually can be translated into saying
if you double the size
you don't need double you only need 75%
more so that says that the bigger you
are the more efficient you are you have
this what is called economy of scale and
indeed I just showed another 1/8 and
this is a very old data it's showing
that this is true across all of life
this same phenomenon even down to cells
this is the same graph I'm not going to
belabor this this is the same line going
all the way down to cells in fact cells
and mitochondria so there's an
extraordinary universality to this and
and I've written it down here that this
extraordinary economy of scale the
bigger you are the less energy you need
for capita and I'm gonna flip back for
one second to this graph to point out
something that I think is very important
and that is the overall scale of this
look at you man and woman and go across
and see how much but how much energy you
need per second to stay alive it's that
bloody light bulb shining at me 100
watts is all you need so each one of you
here kind of spaced out sitting there is
only using a hundred watts so we are
extraordinarily do
have a great economy skills you get
bigger but the overall scale is
extraordinary small all you need is a
hundred watts to stay alive mm food
calories a day which may sound like a
lot is only a hundred watts and I'm
gonna show you at the end and I'm gonna
repeat this if you ask a different
question how much energy do you really
need a day to stay alive meaning or your
cars and electricity and so on your
social metabolic rate so you evolved
only needing a hundred watts so
hunter-gatherers on this planet only
need of order 100 watts still today you
need I need eleven thousand watts bigger
than the blue whale so each one of us in
this room is like a big whale and
there's and word we're moving towards
ten billion people all of whom want to
be big whales this is the problem okay
now this this kind of scaling as I've
written in red there permeates all of
biology anything you can think of any
physiological variable any life history
event scales in a systemic very simple
way and I'm just going to flash on a
couple of them that is heart rate
decreasing systematically this is
lifespan and I'm just going to throw
this on because it turns out the
decrease the rate of which you decrease
your heart rate is exactly the same way
increase of lifespan for mammals and if
you multiply the two together the
increase and the decrease cancel so if
you multiply lifespan by heart rate it
doesn't change from a small shrew up to
the blue whale but lifespan times heart
rate is number of heartbeats in a
lifetime so there's this extraordinary
roughly approximate rule that even
though little things
have lived very fast they're very much
in the fight in the in the fast lane a
shrew beats about heart rate of about a
thousand times a minute a whale's heart
rate is you know boom and you wait a
minute and then it wounds again but they
do it in such a way that they have the
same number of heartbeats and a lifespan
about a billion and a half so if you
understood that number you would
understand why I can make the following
prediction everybody in this room will
be dead in a hundred years and in fact
looking more carefully around okay so
there's the data and here's the point so
here's these extraordinary rules that
permeate biology as they say the most
complex and diverse system in the
universe how come it expresses somehow
this extraordinary simplicity well
here's the answer it's because all of
life is sustained by networks of one
form or another ones you're very
familiar with like the cardiovascular
system respiratory renal system even
your bones your neural system but there
are networks inside cells inside
mitochondria there are networks inside
forests I mean a tree is obviously a
network but the trees themselves
together form a network and what we will
come to when we talk about cities and
companies we of course form a network
but it is the mathematical geometric
organizational properties of networks
that can be put into a mathematical form
that underlie all of those scaling laws
and if you develop the mathematics one
can understand all of those scaling laws
and much more and I just want to flash
on just pictures of networks you're
familiar with that's a little thing that
lives inside an elephant and oh let me
leave that let me leave it there because
it's a beautiful Network and the point
is that you can mathematize these and
all these laws can be derived and
furthermore you can understand the
dynamics of the network so if you
perversely wanted
no you know so to speak the radius
length the pulse rate the blood flow
rate in the ninth branch of a
hippopotamus this surgery system there's
some mathematical formula that tells you
what it is and I don't know what the
answer is autumn assists but I know it's
right for cats mice rats dogs human
beings where it's been measured so let's
go back to growth again very briefly so
here's the theory of growth in in you
know all the bells and whistles have
been taken off and this has to be
mathematize but it's very simple you eat
you metabolize the energy then goes
distributed through the network to
maintain cells that are already there
replaces ones that die and it grows new
cells so you can put that into
mathematics and that's what gave rise to
that beautiful sigmoidal curve for the
rat is this putting this into
mathematics and solving it and I'm gonna
miss this out actually cuz I'm getting
late because it can be applied to cancer
and I just want to summarize some facts
about biology before moving into the
main part of the talk so just to repeat
these are things I've said there are
these extraordinary Universal scaling
laws they have an economy of scale you
have sigmoidal growth you stop growing
and see there I didn't emphasize the
pace of life systematically gets slower
the bigger you are hearts beat I showed
you the heart rates hearts beat slower
systematically you live longer if blood
diffuses across I'm sorry
oxygen diffuses across membranes slower
the bigger you are but everything in a
systematic way obeying these very simple
laws and the claim is that this is
because of the mathematics of networks
and the question is is it true of cities
well citizen networks there's a classic
example but that's just let me just
emphasize something that I said when I
showed you the picture of the mammals so
even though the whale lives in the ocean
the giraffe has a long neck and the
elephant a trunk and I'm standing on two
feet and the shrew can run around fast
on my hand and so on actually those
characteristics are this for the
purposes of this talk are totally
superficial because at the 85 90 percent
level you tell me the size of a mammal I
can tell you everything about it that
its physiology and its life history to
90% accuracy and it and the trunk and
the living in the ocean are that other
10% so we understand at a very
coarse-grained level we understand much
of the way these systems work because of
the networks that sustain them and the
question is can we do the same for
cities and companies because they are
networked so maybe even though New York
and San Francisco and Santa Fe and Boise
may look quite different are in fact are
they in fact scaled versions one another
is San Francisco just to scale down New
York and his Santa Fe just to scale down
San Francisco even though we're in
different geography we have different
history we're made of Adobe you're made
of whatever it is bricks and so on and
so on and so the question is are these
in fact scaled versions is there one
city in the United States and all cities
are just scaled versions of them
according to some simple rules well as I
say they are networks there's one
there's another network that supplies it
but this is the most important network
this is a is really a symbol of the
social network we are part of a social
network we all interconnect with one
another and we cluster in very Universal
kinds of ways beginning with families
and jobs and so on and I will elaborate
on this in a minute but this in the end
is the most important network that
dominates cities not the infrastructure
and we work
to this so here's the first data that we
looked at was asking the very question
our cities in fact scale versions of one
another when we actually look at data so
here's some very mundane data this
happens to be well we were doing it in
Europe these are my some European
collaborators I had gas stations as a
function of size so this is the same
plot that I showed you in biology except
for gas stations and size is we use the
population and here it is it's that same
going up by factors of 10 and what you
see it's pretty good scaling you tell me
the size of a city in Spain I will tell
you how many gas stations it has from
this and what you see is it scales in
all these countries and it scales in a
similar way in each country in fact the
slope of these the gradient of these
lines are all pretty much the same and
they're less than linear this should
drawn it on the graph other graph this
is the linear which would mean double
the size of a city double the number of
gas stations no there's an economy of
scale not surprisingly the bigger the
city you actually need less gas stations
per capita in a systematic way across
Europe but you know something it's the
same graph in the United States in China
in Japan and so on not only that it's
the same for any infrastructure you look
at which I'm not going to show you the
graphs that is you look at the total
length of roads you look at the length
of electoral lines look at the water
lines anything you want to think of to
do with infrastructure you plot it and
it looks just like this anywhere in the
world with the same slope same gradient
so there's this extraordinary University
in infrastructure but much more
important and and in fact this is very
much like biology very much like biology
but this is much more important when we
looked at phenomena that have no
analogue in biology these are phenomena
characteristics that did not exist in
the planet possibly even in the universe
unlikely but certainly did not exist on
this planet
until we started talking to one another
and forming communities eight to ten
thousand years ago and then ultimately
forming cities things like wages and
something that one of my friends Richard
Florida called super creative people you
lot for example and if you plot them in
that same way in the same way you did
the biology you know there's quite a bit
more scatter but you see a definite
scaling trend and what you also see is
the slope of these lines is bigger than
one now not less than one and we call
this super linear rather than sub linear
and what this means is in English that
look at the top graph systematically the
bigger the city the higher the wages per
capita and the more fancy schmancy super
super creative people there are per
capita but you also notice that the
slope of these lines is very similar
about 1.15 there's kind of this 15%
value added the bigger the city and we
will explore that this turns out to be
true for any socio-economic quantity
socio-economic meaning something that
has no simple analogue in biology like
wages and super-creative but it's true
not just in the United States it's
exactly the same everywhere in the world
and it's the same for all the phenomena
that happens to be patents produced in
the United States that happens to be
crime in Japan this is police tax
receipts construction debt and here we
put together one plot and what we did is
we took I forget what it is GDP of the
city the number of patents produced the
number the crime and the income and you
can see they all pretty much follow the
same line and they all have this
roughness
roughly of 1.15 this kind of 15%
value-added and this is true we could
have but this is actually United States
data but it's the same in China Japan
just to repeat myself Chile Colombia
across Europe all the cities that all
the countries were we've been able to
get data so there's this kind of
extraordinary universality which is
remarkable because cities in Japan
evolved completely independently of
cities in Europe or the United States so
somehow agglomerating people and forming
communities no matter what kind of
political process went on or what kind
of planning was inducted no matter what
kind of community action was done on the
average on the average there were these
constraints at work that that made a
city kind of conformed to the scaling so
that if you tell me the size of a city
in a given urban system meaning say in
the United States I can tell you at the
kind of 85 percent level how many police
it will have how many patterns how many
AIDS cases how many hospitals what the
length of roads are etc etc so here's
another way of saying it that if you
double the size of a city then you will
systematically get a 15 percent increase
in the number of patents colleges
created people police crime AIDS flu
pollution but you'll also get a 15
percent savings in infrastructure so
it's kind of amazing and it is no wonder
that everybody comes to cities because
we're very good at ignoring or you lot
to came to San Francisco because of this
bars and all the wonderful things and
the beauty and the good jobs
hopefully etc culture you forget about
AIDS cases and crime and so on which is
also increased in San Francisco conforms
to this actually ok
so um well this is a bit too busy this
slide I apologize but it has a nice
quote I apologize I put it on because
there's this wonderful quote from Goethe
which is relevant which you can read as
I explained the following sorry about
this I'm gonna go back but in biology we
had a similar kind of thing to this but
it was always sublinear
growth stopped economies of scale and
the pace of life got slower the bigger
you are they're all a package and all
because of networks if it is networks
that are giving rise to this if it is
underlying network structure the
mathematics of the network and it is
super linear and it gives rise to super
linear behavior then the pace of life
according to the theory must increase
systematically things get faster the
bigger you are and that's what this
quote was because we know the face of
life gets faster and we check data I
will flash on to this first to show you
a whimsically some data this is biology
this is heart rate this is modern data
and it decreases you can see that the
slope there is very close to 1/4 which I
mentioned earlier but on the right
whimsically we plotted walking speed
versus size and you can see that it
systematically gets bigger it gets
faster the fast the bigger the city the
faster the walking speed and that line
is roughly speaking what we predicted ok
the other thing that happens in cities
is an unintended consequence which is
very good is that the carbon footprint
gets lower the bigger the city is
because here's some data that's really
plotted and watch in the same way
exactly the same way and what you see up
in that corner there is a number which
is less than 1 that point 8 7 whatever
it is 8 8 7 9 roughly 0.9 is the slope
of that is less than 1 which means the
bigger the city the less carbon is being
deposited per person
so cities are fantastic because
everything gets more and you save more
so it's been very very good for us it's
been that's no doubt why all the
wonderful things that have happened in
the last 200 years have been happening
there is an underlying dynamic which
constrains things so that in the things
that we're looking for get more and that
is associated with growth and I've
written down here just summary of what
I've been saying that this super linear
behavior is a result and is feeds back
onto wealth wealth production wealth
creation and in a systematic way and the
pace of life systematically has to get
faster and the last thing I'm going to
talk about cities before talking about
companies and finishing up is I'm gonna
talk about the growth and collapse
because this is the cartoon of what
happens in biology just to repeat you
have sub linear behavior giving rise to
fast growth at the beginning and then
stopping that's a very stable situation
very resilient situation and that is
very bad for cities and economies and it
is a wonderful piece of the theory I
think that if the theory gives rise to
super linear behavior because of the
networks then the same theory the same
equation which takes incoming resources
and roughly speaking maintains what's
there and grows new things that kind of
framework gives rise to this rather than
something that sigmoid and stop it
actually predicts something like this
which is very good faster than
exponential which in fact is what's been
happening and so that's very good except
it has a horrible catch in it it has a
catch which is given by this line it
says as you get bigger somewhere you
approach a line which we call which is
called a finite time singularity that's
just a mathematical phrase but but it's
very important because you as you
approach it you eventually collapse and
on the right hand side
that's what happens to you you stagnate
and then you collapse so you want to
avoid that
how have we avoided that how have we
avoided this and indeed this collapse is
actually intimately related to the
running out of resources whatever it is
that's driving the economy at some point
approaching this dotted line here
there's so called finite time
singularity now have we got out of it we
got out of it because you have to
remember that this kind of growth which
I've put made a cartoon of here was
based on a given kind of paradigm that
is determined by a major innovation that
dominated the culture of whenever
whatever period we're looking at so this
could be the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution you have a coal steam and so
on this could be something that happened
recently namely the discovery of
computers or it could be something even
more recently the transition to IT and
so here's what really happens is that
you start this huge growth if you
continue you would collapse
you innovate which means you start over
again
you kind of set new what we call initial
conditions and you start the system over
again so a major innovation coal has
discovered bloom and off we go but then
we would reach a situation a threatening
situation and we start again so that's
great that's what we've done so there's
a kind of theorem you can derive if this
says if you want to have continuous
growth and avoid collapse you have to
have continuous cycles of innovation and
this is true whether actually for the
whole economy and it's true for any
social organization that you have to
have major breaks that occur driven by
some major change in the
in the socio-economic culture which we
usually think of as a major innovation
that's great except the theory says yes
you have to do this but it also says the
time to go from here to here is
necessarily longer than the time from
here which is necessarily longer from
time there in a systematic way meaning
that that you have to not only innovate
on a continuous way but you have to
innovate faster and faster and faster
according to the rules governed by this
expanding Network so the image is that
not only are we on a treadmill that's
going faster but actually we have to
change treadmills faster and faster so
the real question is is that at all
sustainable can we do that or is it some
way out of this this kind of paradox
that we boxed ourselves into namely that
in order to have wealth creation we need
growth and growth needs to then go in
this kind of cyclic fashion and we need
to have major innovations that to
continue that growth so I just I'm not
going to dwell on this to show you data
but I do want to take I'm gonna come
back to that question in a second but I
want to first talk briefly about I want
to go back I should have done this
earlier too one of these graphs this
graph this is a good one
so there's Tokyo and there's the scaling
line so this is what would be predicted
if we had a complete theory of the
social network and this is the line that
represents the average idealized
behavior of a city anywhere in the world
this happens to be Japan but you notice
up at the top the last dot which happens
to be Tokyo is actually underperforming
it's a little bit lower which means it
has less crime rate than it should for a
city of its size whereas Osaka the next
one
has a little more crime than it should
have for a city of its size
therefore zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom I
should have had that in we can
distinguish the individual 'ti of a city
by how the each city deviates from what
its the scaling line which represents
the idealized you could even use the
word possibly optimized metric for its
size so that's what I've tried to say
here and so this gives a way of ranking
cities according to whether they over or
underperform so we've done that for the
top 363 cities of the United States and
there's a graph just for 2003 patterns
and it's spelt wrongly but the city that
mostly overperformed so I should explain
this make sure you understand it the
straight line across if you sat on that
line you would sit exactly on the
scaling curve for patents meaning you
have the right number of patents for
your size and you can see Phoenix has a
little more whereas Denver has a little
less and so on all the way down New York
isn't very good and the shittiest city
in the world the most in a non
innovative City in nineteen in 2003 was
Abilene Texas and the most innovative
city was Corvallis Oregon and not
surprisingly San Jose is way up near the
top I forget where San Francisco is I
should have looked up but San Jose
because San Jose includes Silicon Valley
and I should have said City here means
metropolitan area we don't use obviously
political boundaries San Francisco when
we say San Francisco we mean the there's
a well-defined or reasonably
well-defined metropolitan area that
urban geographers used to define San
Francisco as a metropolitan statistical
area so this is an interesting way of
ranking them and one of the most
interesting things that came out of it
and this is the reason I want to talk
about I want you to show you this is
what's plotted here
is the time sequence of those deviations
so that line that black line if you won
that black line you would be exactly on
the scaling curve and you would if you
stayed on that line you would 1970 to
2005 and beyond
you would be exactly on the scaling
curve so each one of these points
represents the trajectory of how you've
deviated and the thing that you get from
this is that if you're a shitty City in
1960 you're a shitty City in 2010 and if
you're an exciting city in 2000 and in
1960
you're still an exciting over-performing
City in 2010 meaning that it's very hard
to change cities cities are
extraordinarily resilient and resistive
to major change so all of the stuff that
you do has to take decades so what we
call persistence time is not politicians
time of you know what two years is
infinity its decays 4050 years and there
are very few metrics that you can change
quickly this happens to be patents
patent production we've done it for all
look for most of the the metrics and we
have a map for all the cities and you
could actually there's a website
somewhere you can click and find out all
about these cities and their rankings
I'm gonna talk about companies in a
minute I want to just dwell a little bit
going back now to why it is that we have
these extraordinary scaling laws what is
it I've said networks but what is it
that is universal how come that Japanese
cities and cities in Chile and citizen
United States and in Portugal all scale
in the same way with the same slope so
what is it that is universal across the
globe well the universe salads
of cities and this our people people our
cities this is the most important point
I think to recognize is that it is not
all those beautiful buildings and the
roadways and the slums and the rest
actually cities are a physical
manifestation of our social interactions
the network that connects us and the
network beginning with family I will
call it family but you know family here
means how many people can you actually
have a strong relation with a really
loving I'll use the word love that you
can love well
universally this number is somewhere
between four and six you can have five
hundred best friends on Facebook but
then that doesn't mean anything what
really means something is the people
that you deeply care about and that is
the kind of core of social me I sound
like a rabid Republican in a way but
this this is the crucial anchor of the
whole network structure doesn't have to
be family it's just people that you're
very strongly connected to this is true
incidentally even in families of 15 each
individual actually only connects to
about four or five very strongly you
don't connect to that you don't 15 of
you are not best friends actually so and
that network then goes up because
families then interact jobs and so on so
there's a whole hierarchy of clustering
all the way up the the hierarchy the
social organization and it is that
structure and it is the structure of
those networks that are being reflected
in these scaling laws and why they are
universal because that kind of structure
is a kind of universal structure of the
structure of human interaction social
interaction and social clustering now
one of the clusterings that occurs is in
companies and so i want to now talk a
little bit about companies finish up
and the first question is as we did with
cities we just discovered that kind of
on the average New York is a scaled-up
San Francisco and San Francisco is a
scaled-up Santa Fe from one of the
better one question is what about
companies are companies scaled versions
of one another even though they seem to
be quite different and I'm just going to
show you a teeny bit of data because
this work is very much work in progress
it's not published but I want to show
you this graph this is one of these is
income which one is it the blue is
income and the green is assets of
companies and it's plotted in the same
way in this kind of going up by factors
of 10 as you see and we do the size of
the company by employees could have used
sales doesn't matter actually but there
it is and what you see is extraordinary
scaling I think the top one the one
which has you notice over a million well
as several million employees 10 to the 6
is a million this is Walmart I think so
amazingly Walmart I don't know what this
company is this company have only a
hundred employees is actually a
scaled-up company of a hundred employees
according to its assets and so on so we
have done we have taken actually we've
looked at something like 22 thousand
companies publicly traded companies the
United States and this is not some of
these are international this this graph
but we've looked at 22,000 companies and
we've looked at all of their metrics
that are all their metrics meaning all
of the things that 25 or various
categories
they've report to the Internal Revenue
Service and what we find is scaling
there's quite a lot of fluctuations
actually not seen in this graph but
scaling is terribly important but even
as important is what I have emphasized
before is the slope of that line and the
slope of this line can you believe it is
less than 1 that's what that number is
0.9
that's one point eight point nine it's
less than one meaning that it's
sublinear in the language I used and the
bigger the company two less assets per
employee and the less income total
income of the company per employee it's
very much like US companies are very
much like us
cities have this superlinear very open
everything expanding you saw that growth
everything getting bigger and expanding
companies not like that so if that
theory applies to this you shouldn't get
hockey sticks you should have these
sigmoid curve x' and these companies
turning over and stopping growing that's
not the image that I showed at the
beginning and it's not the image we have
this is the image we have and there it
is this is actual data for Walmart and
it does look like a hockey stick but you
notice I've cheated a little I stopped
it at nineteen ninety four or five
ninety four I think it stopped here's
the latest data and what you see is even
a Walmart is turning over this line is
inspired by the theory this is comes out
of the growth theory that I mentioned
based on networks so that if I'd been a
smart guy in 1990 I would have said
Walmart will be whatever it is in 2009
can do it
but there it is and so there's turning
over but we saw also that organisms like
us turn over like this and and I'm going
to talk a teeny bit about this this is
the signal of stability which is good
but also what's very good it is the
foreshadowing of death so this is the
beginning of death for Walmart
and I just want to show you this
spaghetti graph this is 23,000 companies
in the United States and what everybody
looks at of course is this stuff all
zooming or making money but look
everybody eventually goes flat and
everybody eventually dies as I will show
you in a minute
so just to give you a better I just
sorted out the top companies you can see
they're listed there and this one I
think is Walmart but you can see you see
the bending over and they all end up
pretty much in the same place and
ultimately in the grave now I want to
talk about us briefly if I can take a
few minutes we died and I just showed
you this other this is fun this is all
your various I probably can't read this
let me go over here this is a graph of
all your various functions or some of
your functions so there's maximum
breathing capacity vital capacity renal
plasma and all these marvelous things
that keep you alive and the doctors
measure and this is a plot of the
percentage of how well you're doing as
you get older and what you see is you
improve as you grow and then you
gradually fade away systematically
everything gets worse
yeah it only goes up to 80 and of course
you die now and you see it all goes in a
very systematic way and the question is
that this is not the topic of this talk
this is a whole separate talk is why is
it that we live only a hundred years why
not a thousand years or even a few
months where in the hell does that
number come from why couldn't it have
been a thousand years and where does
that come from
as a scientist from all the molecular
stuff all those genes and so on and
respiratory complex I mentioned
producing ATP well I'm just going to say
some words now as to about dying but
while you're all going to be dead soon
and here's why because it's kind of
poetic the very system that's keeping
you alive the systems those networks are
what we call dissipative which in simple
English means that they have friction in
them you know they we're not surprising
you know you wear out and indeed that's
true those systems by having flows
whether they're macroscopic flows like
in your respiratory system or molecular
flows inside your mitochondria inside
your cells these have some analog of
friction and they can be literally
friction by molecules colliding with
each other and causing damage but also
chemical friction which you've heard of
which is the production of something
called oxygen radicals which damage so
all this damage takes place necessarily
as a byproduct of metabolism and the
metabolic networks and the networks that
distribute energy so natural selection
of course is built into us repair
mechanisms and you do repair but it
becomes incredibly costly to repair
faithfully you know you know that with
your car
it doesn't matter actually how many
times you take it into if you drive it
systems in a systematic way and you take
it in and you get it serviced eventually
it's going to wear out and you're quite
similar you could of course spend an
enormous amount of money and every week
have the engine rebuilt and everything
done and so on but this then of course
all your resources would go to that and
natural selection has of course
allocated energy so that we repair
ourselves enough so they didn't our
quote natural state when we were
biological and just using a hundred two
hundred watts to stay alive we would
live to about 40 and have fifteen to
twenty children in that period of which
maybe half would die and that's what
happened and then we socialized and
we've been able to extend lifespan but
mostly because we have introduced
hygiene
sewers and washing ourselves has been
the major reason for increased lifespan
but then of course all of the wonderful
medicine and so forth so the lifespan is
increased but nevertheless there is a
limit to that at least I believe very
strongly there's a limit to that because
eventually you wear the system and you
can do some calculations which I don't
have time to talk about obviously and
indeed you can see roughly speaking
where this hundred years comes from and
why most importantly how in the hell can
it be that if you're this piece of
tissue here instead of being part of my
hand had been a mouse which it could
well have been it's the same stuff it
would be dead in two or three years
rather and having been part of me for 70
years so this is this this is explained
in fact by the scaling of these networks
so what happens is that of course you
gradually degrade the system and life is
full of fluctuations and eventually even
if you survive all of the diseases and
the cancer and so on eventually a
fluctuation comes along that kills you
after about a hundred no one's lived
more than 123 ever so what about
companies let's take this over to
companies so here's something
interesting that I said we have this
funny old business that all of their
things decrease on a per capita basis
that was the analogue to economy of
scale but most importantly profits and
remarkably profits decrease
systematically per capita meaning per
number of employees or per sale and this
is the most important point sales
continued linearly profits
I'm afraid go sub linearly so per capita
they're decreasing where cells remain
constant and this means that eventually
it cannot be sustained because
it's just like you even though the
profits may be increasing they're
increasing slower than sales and a
fluctuation comes and the company can't
handle it and it collapses so that's
been a typical thing and what the theory
this this framework tells you since its
sub Linea what it tells you is that what
I put there the triumph of economies of
scale over innovation innovation is
associated with this super linear
scaling that's what cities are cities
are innovative they open up
opportunities as they grow they get more
diverse they get more interesting cities
tolerate crazy people we just walk down
Market Street today there are so many
meshuggener people there you can go nuts
but none of those people none of those
people are tolerated in a company
companies do not tolerate crazy people
this is part of their problem it's only
when they ask Stuart and Kevin to advise
them they allow a teeny bit of craziness
in so so when they're less than about 50
to 100 employees you see a lot of
fluctuations and that's because
innovation when a company's form they
pay a lot of attention to ideas and so
on and they're not so worried about
structure and the organization and who's
paying the bills quite but eventually of
course you have to have that this is a
necessity of a company to have a very
good administration and eventually and I
make a cartoon of this a company
basically becomes its bureaucracy and
administration and its innovative parts
get squeezed out and that's what the
data is telling you and these companies
die that's what I've said now let's see
if this I had some trouble with this
earlier
wait it should come up there's a I don't
know why there it is beautiful this is
hot off the press hot off the press so
look at the top right it says
probability of mortality notice it goes
to a hundred percent after about twenty
to thirty years everybody dies everybody
this is companies and summer by let's
say I have to look here because I can't
read it there some go bankrupt and
liquidate and some just of course
required to merge but it's the same
phenomenon and what you see is that put
slightly differently this is
survivability and you see very few
people survive beyond fifty to sixty
years and you can think of companies the
one hundred years old
two hundred years old but very few that
are three hundred there's only one
company that's older than five hundred
years old and that's the Vatican and
that's for very special reasons okay so
I'm gonna finish off to remind you of
this what I said earlier that each one
of you there is using approximately one
hundred watts it's more like it is true
it's more like eighteen eighty to ninety
Watts that's four mm I bet your social
metabolic rate is eleven thousand watts
and you know you're this great big King
Kong and this is the problem everybody
wants to be like this
and it's that's the challenge okay so I
brought up a lot of questions many of
which I did not answer my hinted at
answers but I wanted to give you kind of
this big picture view first of all a
kind of unified view of biology cities
and companies but most importantly to
stress the extraordinary phenomenon that
we've created in terms of cities with
all its open-endedness and its ability
to really stimulate wealth and ideas and
as a side topic to show you the
companies are really much more like us
and they are of course participate in
cities as we do and the cities really
form the background environment
allows all this to happen and then one
of the things that I showed that is the
big question is that to sustain this we
have to innovate faster and faster and
life inevitably gets faster and faster
okay I will finish there
thank you we're gonna go over here and
sit
[Applause]
people all this time you had me up to
all the crazy people sorry
he had me all the way up to the crazy
people I suspect that that did not come
out of your data because you're saying
that companies are sublinear in cities
or superlinear it doesn't know we don't
know we've this work the work on
companies is very much work in progress
as I said that graph of just the
mortality we produced just a couple of
weeks ago so it's you know we haven't
digested all of this but and certainly
none of it is published so I think you
have to take it still with some caution
but what I mean by that I was putting of
course in in a provocative framework
what I mean is that just to repeat what
I said cities as you saw just let me
just graphically are continuously open
open and growing and they don't die and
part of that is that they're continually
bubbling up
I mean reinventing themselves they're
bringing people in immigration to cities
is incredibly important and new ideas
are generated and and we believe that it
is that continuous flow at an
informational level and the opening up
of opportunity that is the lifeblood of
a city and we contrast that and and
indeed gives rise to the super linear
behavior behavior etcetera it's all kind
of one package this is in contrast to
organisms and indeed cities and if we
think of organisms we grow and we stop
but we as individual
do not evolve in our lifespan yes
whereas the species evolves of course of
periods that are much longer than an
individual's life span a city evolves on
a kind of continuous basis and the
implication is that companies after
initial kind of innovative evolutionary
period if we want to call it that but
very quickly tend to become ossified
it's very difficult for them to break
out of a mold you know they're companies
there are certainly exceptions there are
companies that have done this the rule
I've reinvented themselves in some way
the rule I've heard is countries
companies are grown by the engineers and
then they're turned over to the
accountants and then to the lawyers and
then they die yes that's a couple people
saying Penrose and Kevin Kelly both
asked what about nations what about
countries yeah we've not done a lot on
countries and we've done some a little
bit they should be more like cities and
more like cities but the reason we
haven't is that countries cities are
kind of organic they really did you know
they grew much like an organism did even
though they're not organisms but
countries are much more political I mean
they have these unnatural boundaries in
many cases and they're much less organic
and so when we've looked at some of that
data and it's scales and so on but we've
took we've not paid a lot of attention
yet we will another piece and
incidentally other people have looked at
countries stimulated by this so I can't
answer I'm sorry I can't miss Kevin who
was Kevin's I haven't I'm afraid we
don't have we haven't we just haven't
gone there yet you want to after yes we
do and in fact when I go back to Santa
Fe week after next we have collaborators
from Harvard from the Kennedy School at
Harvard who who think in terms of
countries because they are interested
definitely the the Kennedy School and
are thinking much more in terms of
development at the the nation level and
trade trade is very important what
they're thinking about and we want we're
trying to bring these two things
together I can imagine the economist
will you know the trillions of dollars
of financial flow this is a network
offhand sure in some ways we'll see
there's an interesting question from
John Christensen can you predict the
amount of nature parks open space plants
and animals in a city and Los Angeles
famously has approximately no parks yeah
so this is a very this is a very
interesting question very important
question because it the way we have
attacked so one of the things that we've
struggled with are you struggle with
from the beginning of course is what is
the city you know what what defines the
city and I touched on it metropolitan
area metropolitan area and very roughly
speaking this means kind of within
commuting distance you know so that
because it you want to have some some
area where everybody is connected
somehow with someone else so that kind
of defines it now then you ask okay what
about defining the city as an area you
know what's the area of the city and
this brings in exactly this question
density and yes the question of density
and then the question of open space do
you include that do not include it and
so on and I must say the preliminary
data that we've looked at shows very
little systematic behavior of open space
in a city you know there isn't a
systematic scaling and that does seem to
represent much more the individuality
history and geography of a city than all
these other socio-economic
and so like number of parks and stuff
like that doesn't matter so how do we
have the damn things well that's a good
question we have done because people you
know I think that that came presumably
from you know after all in the beginning
cities were populated by migration of
people from small towns and agrarian
communities they had quite an open space
and there was no down some pressure to
have some natural open space oh yeah a
tree I remember trees you would say
stuff like that Paul we ah-has the
question can you make any predictions
regarding the levels of people's
happiness in the size of the cities
where they live well yes so that's an
interesting question again there are
people that have happened you know
measured had invented happiness indices
and we do not have unfortunately there
is not enough data that has done it for
cities they tend to do it for companies
there is southern cities but it's not
enough to really reduce anything there
are wrong companies anonymous arjan
countries and you know since we haven't
dealt with countries we don't know if
there's any systemic behavior and you
know I think isn't it Bhutan is the
happiest country and I think happy happy
but of course you know I mean one of the
things that comes out of that is
happiness is not connected with wealth
and disease and so on does your theory
explain Detroit as question from Philip
who puts it in the terms Detroit meet
the predictability of once exciting
honest exciting Detroit exciting so
exciting exciting in a different way can
you find a job that's well Detroit is
very and brings up another piece of work
that we're moving into so all the data
that was shown here was averaging over
this metropolitan area right so we do
not deep we have not yet but choose what
we want to do if we can get the data is
deconstruct a city Manhattan you know
looking at Manhattan as a subunit versus
the Bronx as a subunit because our data
for New York is the total metropolitan
area including the suburbs so going now
to Detroit so what you find in Detroit
is that of course the central part has
become necrotic it's dying no doubt will
be resurrected in some form but if you
look at the integrated Detroit to
metropolitan area of Detroit despite the
extraordinary failure of the Corps and
the loss of or at least the the serious
decrease in the automobile industry
Detroit has done a remarkable job in the
suburbs of creating kind of a high-tech
industry and if you average over Detroit
Detroit isn't doing so badly actually
isn't doing badly what has happened is
that there has been a migration out of
the core and an attraction of
immigration into the outer rings and the
and Ann Arbor as universities plays very
important role than that it's very
important of course now to if you want
in terms of applying this to planning to
designed to you know political questions
it's very important in this work
ultimately for us to start thinking
about the deconstruction of cities
because we now have we believe the
general rules for a total an integrated
area but now let's deconstruct this
let's look at its heart and liver and
lungs
so you made point going in as the cities
are super linear because they are social
networks and you've probably yeah yeah
and cities were basically a thing that
humans invented so we could expand and
accelerate per social networking you may
have noticed that that's happening
online now yes in a way that has nothing
to do with city limits it just has to do
with access for the internet which is
damn your global does that change the
whole picture
oh that's very very interesting
interesting question which we've thought
about quite a bit and that is the
question that first of all going back to
what I said that you these major
innovations are critical for driving
growth and continuing an upward
trajectory and the latest one has been
the internet and here's the Internet the
city so I'll come to that too in a
second all right
at least talk about everything so the
area code so the question is first of
all the internet provides a different
form of communication and the question
is from this viewpoint does it actually
change the social network and the
dynamics of that social network in a way
that's going to affect cities that's the
first question and I've gone both ways
on that when I first started thinking
about it I thought my god yes because
it's of course the speed of
communication is much faster and the
access is much greater now of course the
counter to that is they wind up in a
scaling way with the quantity of people
on
there's this Metcalfe's law that the
value of a net goes up as the square
root of the number of nodes but you know
we've had other networks been introduced
like the telephone which had a huge
impact it didn't change anything in
terms of this that his human
communication happened in you know
relative to what was before the
telephone have been instantaneously and
it quickly spread throughout the whole
city and there and across the whole
urban system and it has not affected as
far as we can tell any of these
phenomena let me bring it a point that
we came across Global Business Network
years ago which is that basically
corporation is the international
corporations came to pass because of the
telephone and the jet plane and what
that allowed you to do was that Connect
cities into what amounts to a kind of a
world city in which these multinational
corporations live not is this is kind of
a urban phenomenon yes so this is a
variance also very interesting questions
so I have a incipient collaboration
let's call it that actually a
collaboration with researchers in
Singapore
I was recently in Singapore and
Singapore is a very interesting example
everybody's familiar with it it's a city
state but it's a city state like no
other has ever been because it has no
hinterland the hinterland you know if it
were an organic city parts of Indonesia
and Malaysia would be connected with
Singapore but it's completely
disconnected really because it's real
connection is to you know Hong Kong and
New York and London and Rio and so on
and so one of the so one of the
questions first questions is does is
Singapore part of these systems in some
way and so we now have this project
going trying to compare asked first of
all the question if Singapore had been
an American city how does it how do its
metrics stack up you know does it have
okay you know in terms of its roads its
infrastructure in terms of the knob
of AIDS cases number etc etc number of
patents it produces and so on is it
comparable to an American city but more
importantly is is the system that was
now evolving an urban system mainly New
York London Singapore Hong Kong and so
on are they now some global networked
urban system and so with just starting
to look at that data and obviously don't
know the answer but you brought up and I
do want to answer a little bit at least
tell you a little bit about net cities
on the internet okay all these cities
now there are people that have looked at
it we started to look at this and in
fact I meant to contact him just
reminded me Philip Rosedale who invented
second life and Philip Rosedale very
kindly different in what Second Life is
so he spoke on this very stage good
speaker he so he was very kind to offer
us the data for the evolution of Second
Life and could we look at this could we
somehow plot its trajectory and ask the
same kinds of questions we've asked
about it as a city but in particular
does it deviate in some way or are the
various clusters that are forming on
Second Life do they scale like American
cities global cities or is there
something new evolving on the Internet
mmm-hmm so I mean you always say if
these gatherings I've been to a couple
well Google was doomed that's because
you asked me to be provocative
and you know the somebody asked about
does Congress repays would not talk to
me again
oh you will Suzanne asked have you
shared your with the US Congress your
theories about companies dying versus
quote too big to fail with US Congress
was too big to fail in a abomination and
your world probably is well it is in the
sense that you know the the speculation
is what I said earlier that since
companies seem to be very much more like
organisms and it's and in organisms for
you know if you believe in Darwinian
evolution it's very important that
organisms die so that you know new ideas
new phenomena can evolve and I think
that's crucial for the economy I think
that's absolutely crucial for the
economy that companies die and so but of
course there is you know to mitigate
that as in the case of too big to fail
you know I suppose there can be
consequences for the overall economy
that someone some politician judges to
be disastrous for the economy but may I
say I will say a very provocative
statement one of the problems being a
scientist working in this is the
frustration that the people making the
decisions don't really talk to
scientists very very rarely talk to
social scientists they do talk to
economists and so it's a problem so one
of the things I have discovered
incidentally in my talking with
politicians and policymakers and so on
is that most people don't understand
what an exponential is when you say
something is expanding exponentially you
don't understand what it is and a minute
I'll present a little cartoon of that do
it exponential so here it is
so imagine that I want to make a test
tube of penicillin and I know that if I
start at eight o'clock in the morning
with a couple of penicillin bacteria
I'll fill up the tube
okay anew okay so you put these
bacterium in the test tube and it
doubles every second every second is
doubling and I've calculated that by
noon it will be formed question when is
it half full what time between 8:00 and
noon is the tube half one second before
so it's only half full a second before
now think of the following think of five
seconds before five seconds before is
two to the fifth which is 32 so it's
three percent for so five seconds before
is this test tube and it's just this
teeny weeny bit so those bacteria in
there sounds great
doubling growing everything's fantastic
looks like it's infinity to go you know
they don't realize that five seconds
later it's all over that's exponential
growth and that's the problem so Robin
Sloane asked I
[Applause]
the news is best just before the news
gets catastrophic so I have two
questions one from Robin Sloane oh yes
how do we design companies less like
mammals in more like cities please well
I think that's a huge question because I
don't know obviously don't know the
answer I can suggest some things and I'm
not sure they're doable but you know
just at a very simplistic level what
this suggests is that you know when so
what happens in with a company a big
company it it's quite innovative at the
beginning and often as it grows in many
industries it has used to have research
and development but typically what
happens is that as the when times get a
bit tough economies of scale get even
more powerful and you say well don't
need all that research and development
but cut that back because that's costing
us a lot of money it's long term it's
not short term we can reconstitute it in
two or three years when the company's in
better shape some companies like IBM
which is doing well on longevity they
have a rule that they don't cut their
own exactly so IBM is a fantastic case
in that regard Ford General Motors Bell
Labs who had phenomenal or they cut them
and run into deep trouble and that's
typical so that's just a you know a kind
of narrative of the problem that it's
the the easiest thing to cut is
something that looks strategic and
long-term and the way the companies do
it now is they buy the R&D device so
that you are you saying that doesn't
work so the question is so one of the
things that has happened is exactly what
you said is the companies no longer grow
them inside so to speak but when they
see something they think is important
they buy it and try to somehow integrate
it I think the jury's out rose
on that one as to whether that model can
work
I'm very dubious because the the you
know what I know which is not very much
about some of those big companies but
what happens is there is a very dominant
culture in the host company that is very
hard to integrate with the more
innovative buzzing little company that
is try to feed something in and so they
see the great thing they should try not
to integrate these things well they
should but it's very difficult whereas a
city has things like this going on all
kinds of things that are bubbling up and
a lot of a lot of interaction very hard
to do in a company and Google bless
their hearts of course was founded
trying to do that and that's one of its
great characteristics and it's trying
very hard and I you know my own
interpretation of nari page becoming the
CEO again is in fact a recognition that
they need mm-hmm you know more buzz more
city light so to speak and in fact as
you when you go to Google as you well
know much better than I there is that
attempt in the structure of the company
and you know whether that is the panacea
that solves these kinds of things I I
don't know but it's but definitely from
this data it looks as if that it's even
though it may be very difficult in terms
of economic hard times supporting more
speculation and more innovation and more
transparency and collaboration in a
company is critical for its very
long-term future here here
well I think you know what you've done
is define the nature of the problem very
nicely for these organizations I think
it was slightly more cosmic level you've
been very up beat tonight other times
I've heard you emphasize that you know
these cities accelerate their growth
there's a kind of singularity looming
and we keep avoiding it by a sort of a
different dimension of innovation and
then a different dimension but the time
and those gets shorter and shorter and
still we're still going to singularity
verticality craziness and physicists
really hate singularities except in
other people's black holes fine
and then you usually say so this can't
go on forever there has to be collapse
in the picture here somewhere and that
sounds very dire and it sounds like
you're you're saying that cities need to
learn how to be sigmoid 'el in some
fashion or they perish now in history
what are your examples of cities that
have accelerated themselves to death we
don't know the answers of that we think
that some said like Rome has done some
of that we don't know because it's been
very hard to get data we need data
really you know you it's extremely
difficult to get credible data for
either ancient cities or even cities you
know we do have some in fact I didn't
talk about it but we've looked at New
York from 1717 I think recently and New
York has been through periods where it
has gone stagnated and started to
collapse but you can see them so you see
these these things happening in New York
but you also see periods where it's on
the verge of collapse so the question is
so first of all I want to amend what you
said you said cities been in fact that
graph applies potentially to the whole
economy actually that's that the whole
economy has that kind of characteristic
and you could even think of the sum of
all cities being the economy but this
you could apply this same kind of thing
to a total economy and you you know so
what are your examples of economies that
have accelerated till they collapsed
well we don't know we don't know
do you predict they will well this will
I mean the point is that that all of the
evidence and I didn't show there were
two graphs I didn't show at the end show
that first of all this acceleration this
continuous acceleration and in fact the
graph I didn't show is the graph many of
you probably of maybe he's talked in
this series very cuts while so cuts
while even though I quite completely
disagree with his interpretation uh but
I do agree with his the data he's
collected which is fantastic and in fact
he draws a line of the the the goes
through all the major innovations and
interestingly enough the line that he
drew just connecting them is predicted
by this theoretical framework which is
so once your disagreement with Kurtz was
so my disagreement is that he sees you
know the singularity building to where
we will become cyborgs right you know
the next thing something wonderful
something wonderful I see it the
opposite that if you take it to its
ultimate conclusion that the system is
not sustainable and the metaphor which I
said near the end of the talk I didn't
quite complete the last piece I left it
out I said you know we are on a an
accelerating treadmill but we have to
faster and faster we have to change
treadmills which are going faster and
faster and it's gonna make a great
YouTube applause we can't the big
question is can you continue to do that
without having a heart attack the whole
system having collapsing because if you
take it to its logical conclusion you
know so what does that say that says
that the time socio-economic time is not
this time it's not this linear time of
the watch and the clock and the Sun the
earth going around the Sun the time is
governed by
the dynamics of these networks which
tells you that the clock is going
actually faster and faster and faster so
something that took a thousand years to
do ten thousand years ago only takes
twenty years now and that timeframe is
going to get shorter and shorter and
shorter if you took it to its logical
conclusion that is that the same dynamic
continues of work so the question is can
we change that dynamic because that
dynamic is over the edge of the cliff
and you the only way of solving that is
there's dramatic solutions which are of
course going to the stable configuration
of all of us becoming hunter-gatherers
which none of us want the alternative is
I tried it once it sucks so we don't
want that although that may be the
stable configuration of human beings
obviously we want all of this and to get
all of that and have this we need to
somehow change the growth metaphor in
such a way that maybe what we can do is
have a tolerate periods of stagnation
even collapse followed by these
absolutely yes so much more that's and
and that means that we have to adapt we
have to adapt society to change to
change that is both up and down it's not
the image that everything's getting
better mm-hmm
I think has to be thrown out that one is
not sustainable that everything getting
better and bigger and it is very much
one second and it's very much the image
is of those idiotic bacteria thinking
that they have you know what looks like
an infinite time and it's five seconds
left because our growth trajectory all
of the phenomena that we talked about is
growing exponentially how old are you 70
there if you were a 24 year old
physicist hearing this wouldn't it sound
kind of exciting and not so
so my self extinguisher
I tell you Mike what my concern is the
following actually I actually think that
ultimately you know this as I keep
emphasizing this is very much working
progress you know I'm I'm sort of I
didn't do it but I should have sort of
taken off my shirt to my vest and so
I've really let my hair down and that's
what I'm doing here is exposing things
that have not been published and
speculating
so I believe that one could find a way
of of stabilizing the system okay but
but the trouble is that we've left my
concern is less that than we've left it
too late haha that is we should have
started like you did 50 years ago
well maybe not 50 40 years ago thinking
about right right these kinds of
questions these people have been
thinking about long and we have not I
mean we as a society of not we've
blindly gone ahead so for example I hope
everybody realizes this when you know
when when they say when President Obama
says growth rate in the last quarter was
only one and three-quarters percent or
two percent and and the Republicans
clobber him because it's not fast enough
and he's looking for four or five
percent you do realize that 2% still
means it's exponential it's still
exponential it's just a slower
exponential but it's still exponential
we're still like those bacteria that is
the paradigm okay so that's the price so
the question is my concern is we have
that in our heads and we're not going to
sustain it and the thing that's going to
be the problem is social unrest social
unrest when we start getting into
approaching collapsed situations
berserkers blowing up things and stuff
like yeah people getting I mean already
I mean it's amazing that we don't have
people in the streets already frankly
well you know that that's your data
point so you're saying if we think
long-term
somehow managed this essentially it
curved from a deadly self acceleration
to a dynamic sustainability but nothing
you've described yet has been volitional
volitional yes everything just happened
in the system exactly it's kind of
extraordinary there so it's the level of
it's an emergent behavior of this do it
in fact this is part of it right this is
part of the networking and this all of
this going on in this marvelous bubbling
way has somehow led to this kind of
systemic behavior no it's about cities
that's the quote so the question now is
can we actually take control of that ooh
and the question that red people thought
I was weird about geoengineering
attained control of deployment you want
to take control of the civilization well
that's the question is that super
provocative with that you know if we
look at the United States where maybe
the United States you know we we have
this extraordinary concentration and an
extraordinary democracy that has served
as well but it was designed for an
agrarian society it was designed when
only three percent of us were doing all
these things 97 percent of us were
living in tiny Hamlet's and on farms and
that's the system we invented for okay
so Singapore is the future Singapore so
the question is is Singapore 21st
Century City and that's what or 20 and
21st century politics because one of the
things that's happened you know and it's
it's very interesting I don't know I
totally speculate autocracy where we're
dysfunctional with a pseudo democracy
that doesn't you know the cop work at
the moment and it's hard to see how we
get out of this so we all become
Singapore that ain't so bad I'm happy I
like our system
frankly I liked it well you're working
you're gonna go immerse yourself in
Singapore so we expect you to report
back and if that's the future thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]